l'avenir appartient à ceux qui ne se
lève pas tellement belle j'étais pas
raconté toi l'autre jour j'ai pas chez
elles ont fait - b2o classique me suis
dit vas-y julia va même si tout cela
puisque tu es juif est là mais quand
elle se penche clairement pour la faire
je suis en mains moites frissons en tout
le corps tigo l'as tu veux te dise
j'étais comme ça mc braguette ou bracket
tandis que tu sens que ça peut ça ça
peut péter à tout moment j'avais le haut
du jean cabot cgt mal j'avais battu
celle des minimoys là les mimolettes
commander tm a été sérieux à julia c'est
comme notre soeur je savais que c'était
sincère une gaule sancerre qu'on fait